[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance listening to trump's stumble
through an explanation of his social
media use something fundamental about
him has occurred to me something that
has I think escaped our attention even
my attention even though I wade through
the sewer of this man's life almost 24/7
and have done so for 20 months those in
his cult view Trump as the Franklin
Delano Roosevelt of Twitter no I'm not
kidding there are no other comparisons
intended between our 32nd President and
this comic book excuse of a 45th but
something has to be acknowledged about
the exploitation of new media they both
recognized and utilized one for good and
one for evil because we might learn
something about how to stop this evil
one there are no statistics as to how
many Americans had ever heard or seen a
president speaking live as he spoke
before FDR White House historians point
out that George Washington went on a
three-month tour of this nation before
he was sworn in and if he was heard by a
thousand different people every day he
was still heard by only 100,000 in total
we know Warren Harding was broadcast on
radio from a ceremony in 1922 and had a
potential audience of about 125 thousand
the State of the Union address from
Calvin Coolidge in 1923 was broadcast it
could have been heard by up to 23
million but on March 12 1933 when
Roosevelt gave the first of his fireside
chats eight days after his first
inauguration it is unlikely that more
than a tiny percentage of Americans had
ever heard a president or a
president-elect speak and speak
intimately live not to a distant crowd
or to a convention or with the formal
rhetoric of eggnog Eurasian but to speak
to them in their own homes
as if he were in the other room 60
million Americans heard Roosevelt that
night in the middle of the 1933 crisis
when the banks were closed for much of
that year there had been bank runs lines
of depositors panicking trying to get
their money out but after Roosevelt
calmly explained what he was doing to
fix the problems in the banking system
and the banks reopened
suddenly there were lines of depositors
waiting to put their money back in
Roosevelt would make 27 more fireside
chats they remain a landmark in
presidential communication it is less
widely known that FDR had tried this
process out as early as 1929 while he
was governor of New York often asking
listeners directly for their help in
passing liberal legislation through a
conservative state legislature it is
even less widely admitted by Roosevelt's
admirers that what he was doing was
intentionally bypassing the mainstream
media
it cannot misrepresent nor misquote said
his press secretary Stephen early about
live radio it is far-reaching and
simultaneous in releasing messages given
it for transmission to the nation or for
international consumption it sound like
anybody we know
tweeting is like a typewriter when I put
it out you put it immediately on your
show so when somebody says something
about me I am able to go Bing Bing Bing
and I take care of it I can express my
views when somebody expresses maybe a
false view that they said I gave yes
he's an idiot and his quotes read like
somebody who just got hit on the head by
a low flying duck but in between the
inanity z' is an essential truth just
like Franklin Roosevelt Donald Trump
figured out how to bypass the
established media how to force it to
report only what topics he wanted it to
report how to get his quote exactly the
way he wanted it and how to at least
start if not utterly control the
narrative moreover just as sitting
around your home in 1933 hearing the
president addressing you just you or
just your family not an audience full of
people at a speech it was an utterly
novel and bonding experience how do you
read Twitter is it you as part of a
crowd do a bunch of your friends get
together and you all read the same
tweets or is it just you by yourself
reading what the people you follow have
written in essence to you how many times
do you confuse a tweet with a Twitter
direct message or even a text if you
love trumpet is easy to dismiss what he
does there asthma
you'll ative morally barren corrupt and
dishonest but two people in the cult
that's him
talking to them just them individually
one at a time the only practical
broadcasting knowledge I was ever taught
in college was by a professor who also
ran the radio stations that Cornell
University owned whenever I hear
somebody say hello world or good morning
Ithaca used to say I look around to see
if somebody's come into the room with me
communication is individual don't say
good evening everyone just say good
evening in almost every speech Barack
Obama would start with hello Chicago or
hello Phil in city name here or on
occasion hello America and I would
cringe amazingly for such a strong
speaker he never got this point people
don't want to hear a speech they want to
have a conversation even if you are the
only one talking at the moment
Trump presumably from his years as a con
man knowing that you rip people off not
in large groups but one at a time
recognize this in Twitter as long as he
has that access he will have core
support this was a metaphorical war for
his cult his election was to them what
Pearl Harbor was to Japan and he has
perfected the fireside tweet he may
truly have absolutely nothing of any
meaning to sell them but he can sell
something to them anyway you know he
added on the subject of Twitter you have
to keep people interested without social
media I'm not sure that I would be here
talking I would probably not be here
talking we can only guess if there was
an unconscious admission in there about
the Russian Facebook ads but we don't
have to guess about the larger point it
is painful to contemplate this but he is
the FDR
of Twitter resist remove piece so I
don't have to keep filling your Twitter
feed with promos the book is called
Trump is effing crazy and it can be in
your hands today from a bookstore or
online buy a copy and I'll send you my
personalized thank you via telepathy